Oh
we are living through in a sixty seven
year period that stretches from 1945 to
2012 a compressed version of a larger
historical epoch four thousand three
hundred and six years long that also
ends in 2012 so that we have reached by
this recommend the late 700 right now
this is what we are living through and
ahead of that slide in the docket
Renaissance the Renaissance the European
enlightenment the discovery of the
Newtonian McKenna
the discovery of the new world that all
lies ahead of us it all has to be
compressed into the next 22 years of
time and that is what accounts for the
crazy quality of modernity with what
accounts for fads and fashions
you know hemlines are rising and falling
in a rhythm based on the rise and fall
of Empires millennia ago and these
things are as causally linked as the
orbit of the earth is linked to the Sun
you see because we are being drawn
toward the attractor through shorter and
shorter epochs and not only must the
entire last 4,000 years of history be
compressed into this 67 year period from
1945 to 2012 but there is a 384 day
period preceding December 22nd 2012 when
the last 67 years and the last 4,300
years have to be compressed into that
then there's the final six day period
when all of these things are compressed
again and so you see what's happening
this spiral is tightening as it goes
faster and faster the resonances are
impatient the thing is getting nuttier
and nuttier and nuttier as computers
link all cultures together all
informational barriers dissolve
everything is becoming connected to
everything else not only everything in
the present moment but all past moments
as well are being blonde compressed
squeezed toward the production of the
transcendental object at the end of time
which is nothing less than all time all
space shrunk down to an atomic dimension
and handed back to us Pfc